[Music]  Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott are madly  in love I love it the beauty moguls  rapper beau loves her so much he  referred to her as his white feet while  wishing her a happy 21st birthday on  Instagram but a source tells ET the pair  hasn't tied the knot quote it was just a  term of endearment although the two are  madly in love they are not married  Kylie recently celebrated her milestone  birthday alongside friends and family  the source revealed Travis also  surprised her with a romantic  celebration of their own quote Kylie's  21st birthday was more than she could  have imagined Travis surprised her with  an incredible vintage rolls-royce and  thousands of flowers while the two were  having a romantic dinner at home over  the weekend the celebrations continued  as the couple hopped on a plane to keep  the party going in Sin City  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]